i welcome those who have just joined
let's wait for others to join as well
and then we may begin
hi dummy hi david
good morning dr chipotle how are you
good morning i'm fine how are you i'm
fine as well thank you it's really good
to have you here with us today
thank you it's great to be here
it's okay dummy
we would be starting in a y
let's wait for others to join as well
and as you are joining the session
please make sure that you keep your
microphone on mute
abhishek this is a free webinar and we
don't provide certificates for free
webinars
because here we are today just to
discuss about our upcoming program
so to get the certificate you have to be
a part of the program
and then yes you will definitely get a
certificate for your participation
and also for excellence for carrying out
assignments
on excellent performance thank you
okay so i think we should begin now and
others
may join in the y so i welcome you all
for today's webinar on bioinformatics
for precision medicine
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand
and diagnose and treat major
life-threatening diseases
the transformation is driven by high
throughput molecular data
that is being collected from patients
animal models
and last large scale cell line
experiments
in this program we will explore how the
various omics data types generated in
these studies can be analyzed
and integrated to study the basic
biology associated with
viruses and their hosts cancer onset
and development and outcomes as well
my name is sunalika ray and i'm the omix
logic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of
users that are a part of a
bioinformatics
community managed by pine biotech
before we start with the talk i would
want to introduce us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
omixlogic research based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omics logic is an international program
that is running
in five different regions with over 10
000
users around the world due to this fast
growth our team is working with local
and regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program logistics
and leverage our online training
resources adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world
this online program includes weekly
sessions
with an instructor online tracking and
review of student progress
access to all the resources and
materials online for
self-paced learning access to expert
guidance in problem
solving educational and research
pipelines
and domain data analysis on our big data
server for 15 days
let me introduce you to the program
mentors dr harpreet
has an expertise in the application of
statistical machine learning techniques
and biomedical data and the development
of prediction tools and databases
and looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumdar who is an experienced
by implementation with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industrial
academia
over the past several years he has been
developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project lead for omixlogic training and
research fellowship
dr jeffuliano chavez post-doctoral
fellow at university of chicago
he is skilled in bioinformatics and an
expert in glioblastoma
now to speak about the program and why
bioinformatics is a critical component
of precision medicine
let me pass it on to ceo pinebiotic ilya
brodsky over to eureka
thank you everyone uh thank you so much
for the introduction
and i wanted today to speak briefly
about why bioinformatics for precision
medicine
why it's such an important topic and how
can you
get acquainted with some of the
important challenges
that are yet to be solved and the
methods
that could be used to address some of
those questions
so before i begin i wanted to mention
that
our company is a technology transfer
company that
originated at the tower bioinformatics
research center it's a research center
from
university of haifa in israel and what
we have done is we have taken
the innovation that they have assembled
together
in an online computational platform and
packaged it
with additional training resources and
project
examples and this has been a work of
our team so not only myself but people
that
are highly experienced in these domains
including bioinformatics training
content
delivery and things like that and so as
a result what we've really built
i think is a community uh
that is beyond just the training and
the goal of omitologic programs is
actually to provide
the training in bioinformatics but it is
to enable independent research
that is guided by experts in peer
example
and this growing community i think
shares the passion for data-driven
research and an appreciation of citizen
science and what that means really is
that
all of us can ask questions all of us
can have hypotheses
what i think unites us is our
appreciation for
data and evidence that we can find in
that data
and therefore we appreciate the skills
that are needed to be able to ask those
questions
and get those answers correctly and so
as a result i think that these programs
are enabling
thousands of students around the world
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life and data
sciences and so that's why we don't
think that we've figured everything out
and so we continue to build our network
of mentors
and contributors to the program and
that's why it's important for us to
maintain this growing community and we
have two social media groups
and maybe some anika you could paste the
links to our
linkedin group and to our facebook group
so we have a group on linkedin called
omixlogic and it's dedicated to machine
learning biomedical data
mining and high throughput data analysis
and also
a big data analysis group of over 2 000
members
on facebook so please join us there
connect with us and connect with our
mentors if you are a mentor
or you want to be a mentor please join
and let us know
if you would like to be a contributor in
some way
please also reach out to us directly
so let me start first by uh highlighting
some of the things that probably many of
us already know
uh for example cancer which is one of
the leading causes of morbidity and
mortality
worldwide is much more prevalent
in areas of the western world that has
a growing and older population and so if
you think about that trend of the
population becoming older
and having additional comorbidities
it is clear that to address this
effectively
the same standard measures that are
working for everyone
are not going to work for any particular
individual
in a very precise and effective way
and so it's very important for us to
recognize this trend
and to understand what are some of the
ways that we could effectively address
this growing problem
that is going to require much much more
investments
in new technologies to address these
pressing needs
for example when we think about cancer
we need to understand
what are the drivers of cancer
progression what are the risks
associated with developing cancer
and therefore develop screening and
early diagnostic
tools to develop what are to
develop an understanding of what are the
markers of cancer risk
and progression and so in that
kind of approach what we're really
seeking to understand
is how can we detect these molecular
signatures
that are very specific and unique
to each individual and be able to
recognize
that small piece of data that signal
out of noisy huge data sets that are
generated every day for millions of
patients around the world
and what that has to do with are new
technologies that
allow us to look directly into the dna
understand the genes and rna
transcription
and look at the sequences of individual
cells and tissues as this
disease develops over time and so what
we're looking at
is really a collection of complex data
sets that include
patient-derived cell lines
patient-derived xenograft models or
animal models
with human tumors in them so the cell
lines and the
patient-derived xenograph models are
some examples of how we can study the
basic biology behind this disease
but also we can incorporate the clinical
trials
and some of the big data collected from
real patients
where we can find some signature
information
and start to ask questions and
eventually what we're seeing as a result
of that
is more precise and targeted therapy
for many diseases including cancer
therapy
and a lot of these are actually changing
our ability to
treat people more effectively based on
these molecular signatures
combining our understanding of drug
metabolism
with our understanding with genetic
predisposition
and with an appreciation of disease
progression or the basic biology behind
how this disease goes from non-malignant
to more and more malignant and invasive
and eventually metastatic cancers
that ultimately lead to death and so
this appreciation of
data really is central to our ability to
be able to provide more effective
and precise treatment of patients now
unfortunately
what that brings us to are some big
challenges
with data that is very diverse
very different because it was generated
by
thousands of labs around the world
different hands
different methods and approaches it was
generated from many different types of
people we don't know all the information
about those people
so really it's a problem of big data and
this problem of
big data is a different type of a
challenge
than what clinicians and biologists are
used to so biologists coming from a life
science background are used to
clean data experimental data data that
had a design
data that had very specific parameters
included in how the data was generated
and therefore you can test your
hypothesis
by looking at the signal in that data
and for clinicians i think it's even
much more challenging than that because
what they're used to be
dealing with is data that is not high
throughput it is
data that is obtained from lab reports
those lab reports come with a medical
history with a medical background
and are contextualized by medical
knowledge
that that individual or that location
really has
and so as opposed to that when we come
to this
challenge of big data in the clinical
application
we need to appreciate some things that
are coming really from the research side
as well as understand the context
for many different patients that we
could potentially not
ever interact with but they're really
repositories of raw data
that we can mine and extract some
meaningful signatures from
and potentially that could help us
answer some important questions about
the patients that we interact with
and so at the baseline of this i think
is one of these technologies and this
technology is called next generation
sequencing
and i think that for many of you
probably you've heard a lot about
genomic data you've probably heard about
the applications of genomic
medicine in a variety of different
diseases but i think what is important
is for everyone to have
that skill set and have that expertise
in being able to look at the data
understand its quality be able to
find specific signal and then to also
lead to biological or
even clinical interpretation of that
signal
and that's really what this program is
going to be about so we're going to
introduce you to a number of different
ways to study this kind of data
analyze sample projects that we've
prepared and curated for you to
understand the specific questions
and the applications of that data set
and then introduce it to some of the
methodologies that will be useful for
you to
practically work with such data sets
understanding
genomic variants understanding gene
expression and the variation in gene
expression based on differential gene
expression
looking at the annotation and
interpretation of how these
differentially expressed genes could be
combined
into specific biological pathways and
how can we really understand the
biological pathways
in the context of a particular disease
or a biomedical question and so one of
the repositories that we will turn to
is what's called the cancer genome atlas
or tcga
now tcga is a very important
repository of thousands of samples
collected from patients that are
that have many different types of cancer
so coming from different tissue and
binding sites
and what it provides us is some kind of
an appreciation for
multi-omics data and its role in
understanding the disease stratification
so how
is disease uh variable between different
patients
patient stratification how different
patients
are represented in this data set they
come from different ethnic backgrounds
different age groups different
sexes genders and how can we
use this data to understand the disease
in a much more precise way so this is
a really unique repository that actually
anyone can gain access to
and start downloading that data to be
able to ask
research questions finding associations
between
treatments between risks between
different types of omics data and so
what we will address in this program
is how to integrate such data to be able
to find
patterns that are relevant to
different types of cancers we'll also
take a look
at some of the algorithmic approaches
that allow us to apply
machine learning to extract
signal from data sets that were
generated in a high throughput way
and so one unique aspect of high to
high throughput experiments is that the
data has been generated
in an automated way and we can generate
such data
from cell lines based on for example
response to treatment
so ultimately the goal there is not to
understand the molecular mechanisms
behind
efficacy of drug treatment for example
but it's really to find associations to
understand some signal some kind of
biomarker
of efficacy and that kind of information
can then help us assign better
treatments to patients
not by understanding and studying each
patient individually
but actually running some algorithms
that could bring out that information in
front of the
uh in front of the person who is
delivering the treatment
and guiding them in their decision
making so there we will take a look at
how
actually both of these are integrated so
we'll take a look at
animal model experiments cell line
experiments and then compare them
to the variability in patients looking
at
research articles that describe the data
sets
and trying to extract signal that is
aligned
between cell lines animal models and
ultimately addresses the challenges
with individual patients now in addition
to cancer
many other diseases are going to be on
everyone's mind obviously we live in an
era of a pandemic
and so it's important to appreciate the
role that
viruses play not only in the pandemic
that we're experiencing right now
but also in many other conditions so a
lot of times we think of infectious
diseases like source growth ii
as a virus that is causing a pandemic
but surprisingly many different viruses
are involved in a variety of diseases
for example
epstein-barr virus is involved in many
cancers
hepatitis can lead to liver cancer so
there's many
diseases including neurological diseases
that could be associated with either the
direct
effect of the infection or inflammation
that is caused by chronic infection and
so we'll take a look at
how other types of diseases could also
be studied using technologies like
next-generation sequencing
to understand the disease itself
the immunology or the host response to
that disease
and the variability in disease
manifestation in many different types of
patients
because of what is actually going on in
different tissues
and cells that we look at through the
lens of data
and so that's why i think that
bioinformatics
is really central to our ability to
improve
medicine and improve treatment that is
more effective
less toxic and guided by our
understanding of these molecular
signatures
and so to develop bioinformatics skills
you need to have some sense of the
biology
computer science and the statistical
methods that are used to analyze such
data
and so we hope that as a result of this
program what you will be able to gain
is an understanding of a variety of
bioinformatics algorithms and software
to appreciate the different databases of
data
that includes genomic data from cancer
studies infectious disease studies and
other diseases
you will appreciate the analytical
techniques
and approaches that are needed to
analyze data and you will be exposed to
a variety of data science skills that if
you are interested in
you can pursue further in other types of
training
to develop a practical skill set that is
needed
for the age of big data and so as an
example
we have here a few omics data and
infectious disease research that i think
will also cover in many of the sessions
that we'll discuss
that will include an overview of viral
genomics and evolution
immune response biomarkers as well as an
overview of microbiome and its role in
infection
now obviously a lot of what i'm saying
seems like
too much to cover in a single program
and so that's why
what our team has done is collected a
number of program resources
that we're going to be making available
to all of the program participants
to make this a more streamlined and
effective use of your valuable time
so we will not only cover these live
sessions like we're doing today
we're also going to provide you access
to our training materials
fast big data analysis tools that you
can run
via a visual graphic user interface
curated project data sets so you don't
have to spend all of your time
finding data but you will be given some
data sets that you can quickly go
through to understand
the point and the connection between the
analysis and the biological
relevance as well as these interactive
sessions
that will be guided by mentors that i
will introduce in just a couple more
minutes
but before i do that i want to introduce
you i know that some of you are probably
already familiar with this
but i'm going to briefly speak about our
big data analysis platform
that allows anyone to quickly go through
some of the important methods in
bioinformatics
and try them out on different types of
projects
so we will in a second go into
how to register and how to create an
account and once you do
we will take a look at this big data
analysis platform
so that you can understand that you can
both learn and then
use this platform for actual research
projects that you might have
and so here you will find a variety of
different types of omix data that you
can analyze
you can run demo pipelines to understand
the logic behind
some of the different analyses that we
will use you will also see how you can
share your analysis with someone else so
that someone
like a mentor can provide you with
technical information about what went
wrong
in your analysis and it also includes
user-friendly tools to apply
data mining and annotation of biological
information so that you can get quick
insights about the data sets you're
analyzing
so to really see how all of this works
let's go to learn.omicslogic.com
and let's start by creating an account
and that will allow us to take a look
at some of the data sets and some of the
example or projects that we will cover
in the program
okay so to go there so
if you could please share the link
okay so when you get to this program
sorry when you get to this portal learn
onyxlogic.com
uh you can create a free login
this login is going to be free for
anyone you don't have to participate in
the program
in fact if you would like to use this
asynchronously you can
okay when i share my screen let me stop
sharing just real quick
um so when you create your account
you will gain access to both the
coursework
and the um both the coursework
and the platform
okay so here you can see that you can
create an account
for free those of you that don't have an
account you can do that now
i'm just going to sign in
and once you're in i will show you what
are some of the resources that we will
be using
and later on i will pass it on to
sonalika to also look
at how to register for the program
itself
okay so please let me know once you're
in
and once you have an account you can
put yes or number one or something like
that in the chat box so that we know to
proceed
okay so i see people signing up right
now
so if you have not signed up yet please
sign up i want to
demonstrate how the program resources
are going to work
okay thank you david
all right thank you dr bashir
okay so hopefully you've created your
account now
you will find that your account comes
with
a personal profile and in this profile
the first thing that you want to do
is you want to finalize your name your
profile picture give us some description
about you
and this is going to become your
personalized center
of your learning experience so here you
will find
the courses that you are taking your
progress if you've completed some course
you will see a certificate
you will also see your certificate
separately here if you would like to
download them
but importantly you're also going to
have these programs here
and so once you join one of the programs
again you will see
what are the specific things that are
associated with each one of our programs
so if you go to the programs tab
here here you will find all of the
upcoming programs that we have
and in this particular programs on
precision medicine
we have included a number of courses and
projects
that are going to be relevant for your
ability to learn
and apply bioinformatics techniques to a
variety of
questions and examples so here you will
find projects like
the cancer genome atlas an example with
liver cancer project
you will see some projects on cobit 19
you will see some technical skills that
are going to be useful
as you learn to integrate visualize and
analyze your data
and you will see a number of
explanations about some
important machine learning techniques
that we will cover in the course as well
so take a look at this and later on
zononica will explain exactly
how this program is organized to
continue
and pass it on the
main component i think that
differentiates this program
from some of the other programs that
you will find online on similar topics
is that this
is not just access to these online
resources
this is access to training material
big data processing which you will
typically not find
in anywhere else and this is going to
give you some
real examples of
methods to process your data and so to
briefly introduce this
resource all of you that have an account
you can use the same account to access
a demo pipeline that i will briefly
demonstrate
to show you how easy you can go from
learning about
a specific method of analysis to
actually using that method of analysis
and so to do that i will go under the
transcriptomics section
and i will open a number of demo
projects that we will use
during this program so one of them is
called the cell line project and so this
is a project where they took
a variety of cancer or breast cancer
cell lines
and performed gene expression analysis
so they generated
transcriptomic data to understand
what differentiates between different
types of breast cancers
so here we can quickly process the same
data
and as we go through the analysis
appreciate
what are some of the logical steps that
you need to take
to go from raw next generation
sequencing data fast q files
all the way to getting a table of
expression so the main
steps are pre-processing mapping and
then
quantification of expression levels and
what i'll do today is i'll build
a very simple pipeline that in reality
if you were to
try and make this pipeline on your own
might take you maybe
a few hours a few days or even a few
weeks depending on your level of
expertise but you'll see how quick
and simple this could be right here so
first of all
what we'll do is we'll clean up those
raw reads
and we'll make sure that we remove the
technical adapters
from library preparation we will then
address the
issue of pcr amplification that could
bring in some technical variation that
we don't want to confuse with biological
simple
uh signal then we will align
these reads to the reference genome
using botym2
and then we will quantify the levels of
expression
to get a table of fpm gene expression
using our send once we've completed this
pipeline i can click on
end and i will take a look at some of
the output data
so it's a real quick process to go from
having that raw data to then analyzing
that data and you
saw some of the variations into the
pipeline that you can make as you go
through
and then get getting a result so that
you can appreciate the inputs and the
outputs very quickly
once you get those results importantly
we have
all kinds of additional methods to mine
this data visualize this data
and even integrate multi-omics data to
quickly understand the relationship
between
gene expression genomic variants
maybe microrna and long non-coding rna
as well as some clinical information
given it is structured in the proper way
so we will go through all of these tools
but another thing that i want to mention
about this program
is that it is the resources and the live
sessions and big data analysis tools and
curated data sets
but another major component are really
the experts that come to the program to
provide you with mentoring
so if you're a researcher or even a
student or a citizen scientist
and you want to develop a research
project one of the challenges that
you're going to face
is really getting the knowledge that you
need quickly
to select a project identify a data set
translate your idea into a technical
requirement that you can execute on
and there are many many challenges along
the way and so instead of learning from
your own mistakes and trying to do this
by trial and error
it is always beneficial to turn to
someone that has gone through the
process that you are looking at
and leverage their expertise to make
your project
more uh more effective and more
ambitious perhaps than what you would be
able to achieve on your own
and so to briefly introduce our mentors
we have a collection of mentors that
we've been
uh building a network with and and we
want to
give them opportunities to share their
expertise and their experience
and so briefly i want to introduce
dipoliano chavez
who is a postdoctoral researcher
at university of chicago and
deals with glioblastoma so depaliano
over to you
hello everybody good morning i apologize
because i am in the lab and i
it's still mandatory to use a mask over
here
as elia was saying i'm a postdoctoral
scholar here at the university of
chicago
i work with neuroblastoma
actually it's a type of cancer derived
from the formation of the central
nervous system in
kids it's a pediatric cancer
i will share some a couple of slides
with you
so that you can get a better sense of
the
types of answers that we can study
with bioinformatics so i
chose the title for this towards a
better classification
of neuroblastoma tumors
so as elia was saying we can use a broad
variety
of data types to analyze tumors
i also have other projects where i deal
with infectious diseases but today i
decided to
talk to you about neuroblastoma because
i think in general people are really
interested in
cancer also this is a pediatric cancer
so i think it's really appealing
to uh think about ways in which we can
help
kids grow more more healthy
and safer so the problem uh
with neuroblastoma you can think from
this perspective
so the tumor is formed basically of a
heterogeneous
mass of cells and i want to highlight to
you
that there are two major cell types in
neuroblastoma tumor these two major
types are the adrenergic type
which seems like
a neuron so you can see these
projections in this in the cell
cytoplasm here
and that's what gives them the
characteristic of a neuron and remember
that i said the neuroblastoma is derived
from the development of the central
nervous system
the other population that is very
important for neuroblastoma development
is the mesenchymal population of cells
these cells
uh are not differentiated
so when when i s when i speak about the
neuroblastoma you can
sorry when i when i speak about an
adrenergic cell
and that it looks like a neuron you can
think of the concept that it's a
differentiated cell so compared to the
adrenergic cells the mesenchymal cells
are not
differentiated the mesenchymal cells are
not
tumorogenic in the sense that they do
not grow
as a tumor but the problem is that these
cells they can
differentiate into an adrenergic cell
and that is the problem because although
they are not tumorogenic themselves they
can differentiate and become tumorogenic
mesenchymal cells are not sensitive to
chemotherapy so in fact
after you give chemotherapy to a child
these cells are going to survive and
they they're going to cause the cancer
to relapse because as i said they're
going to
they're they're likely going to
differentiate and
give rise or start disease progression
as an adrenergic cell so this leads to
the idea
in the field that these mesenchymal
cells are responsible
for a process called a concept called
the minimal residual disease concept
where you give chemotherapy to the child
you kill
some of the adrenergic cells but
the mesenchymal cells they are not
killed by chemotherapy they stay alive
they can differentiate into amazing
adrenergic cells and then therefore the
cancer relapse
relapses or disease the disease
progresses
as i said adrenergic cells are
tomorrowgenic
and they are sensitive to chemotherapy
there are many ways in which we can
classify these adrenergic and
mesenchymal
cells or rather adrenergic and
mesenchymal tumors
and these are some of the technologies
that we use to classify
these cells and the tumors so
this paper is from 2017 and people used
rna-seq
so you can see this is a technique
called
a machine learning technique called
hierarchical clustering
so you can classify the mesenchymal
cells
and they are they are different than the
adrenergic cells so you can basically
segregate separate or cluster
the adrenergic investment kind of cells
you can also
classify these cells using uh
biochemistry
experiments this is a western blot it's
based on the interaction between
some of the proteins that are
characteristic of the adrenergic and
mesenchymal cells with antibodies this
is an immunological method
this is a another method that is based
on
scoring you basically associate a number
with a mesenchymal energy characteristic
so
as i said this is using rna-seq data
there are also a different type of
classification where you use
other than rna-seq you use chromatin
immune precipitation sequencing
and that's based based on chromatin
accessibility
so these enhancer regions are regulatory
regions that interact
with the cellular machinery that is
responsible for the
expression of the genes basically the
expression of the proteins
so it's really a uh this is
at the level of epigenetics not genetics
so this is a level above uh genetics
because
it's it is thought that the epigenetical
epigenetic level of pacification
is happens before the actual gene
expression
as i it's illustrated here on the right
part
these um these chromatin
immunoprecipitation peaks
they can also be used to classify
the mesenchymal cells and the adrenergic
cells
one thing that is really interested
interesting about the
these epigenetic methods is that they
can just be used as i
showed with the rna-seq and this is a
principal component analysis showing the
separation or the
clusterization of these again these
adrenergic invasion of cells
but here not using gene expression
uh here it's using the super enhancer
regions the
the data that comes from the chromatin
immune precipitation
so really what is established
nowadays is that you can separate
basically the group of kids that have
neuroblastoma into two basic
groups that are the
high risk group and the non-high risk
group so as you can see in this survival
curve
the group of kids that are classified as
a
high risk they have a very lower
significa probability of survival
compared
to the group of kids they are classified
as non-high risk
but once you classify the tumor of a
child as a high risk tumor
there is basically no way that you can
use to predict
the prognosis of that of that group of
that
of that tumor so in neuroblastoma
after again after a child is classified
as having a high risk tumor you cannot
predict
how that tumor is going to act whether
it's going to
progress malignantly or whether it will
not
but one thing that gives us hope give us
some hope
is the fact that the mesenchymal cells
may provide
some sort of prognostic ability because
as i said these are the cells that
survive
chemotherapy so if we are able to
detect these cells and the percentage
of these cells that are present in the
tumor
we think that we really have some sort
of prognostic
ability in uh for deciding
what to do about the treatment of a
child
so i'm going to finish now because this
is basically the
the the work that i'm doing right now
uh which is to use to develop these
mesenchymal scoring systems
uh to classify high-risk tumors so
we basically compare the uh
gene expression the epigenetic profile
profiles of the mesenchymal and
adrenergic
tumors and we then try to see if that
has some
uh prognostic value so i'll briefly
explain this to you
because this is really the um the
the the fundaments of the research that
i'm doing so this is in
uh i'm still working on this this is not
published yet but what we can see
what the our data suggests is that the
mesenchymal scores
in fact have a very uh good
relationship or a good
association with low survival
probability and therefore we think that
this method can be used to
quantify the genetic profiles of these
kids
that are on the high risk group
and therefore we can test some
treatments and we can
propose that
we have ways to measure and to determine
whether
a high-risk tumor is going to have
a good or bad prognosis so i would like
to
end with that statement that
we think that we can find
ways to classify high-risk neuroblastoma
tumors
using these bioinformatic technologies
and the combination of dna sequencing
and
bioinformatics analysis thank you very
much for the invitation
thank you so much dr jabilano
and now before i pass it on to dr mohair
to discuss the session details let's
quickly
uh have a poll launched to know you all
better
so i've launched a poll and i would be
keeping it on
for a minute and let's see what we get
as answers so my first question is what
is your designation
undergrad grad post graduate
faculty researcher administration and
what
is your research interest data science
bioinformatics
neuroscience precision medicine or
infectious diseases
thank you for your answers i would be
keeping the
uh pole on for uh 30 seconds
thank you all for answering dr mohit
over to you
thank you sunalika
okay thank you ilya and jupiter for this
wonderful
uh talk about your project and also
about
bioinformatics for precision medicine
hello everyone my name is mohit mazumdar
and i'm one of the
co-project mentor of the program so
as as for today let us go through the
through the sessions that we are going
to have uh what actually india discussed
and what we have in the curriculum
how that aligns with uh the subject and
the importance of what we discussed
today
so let me let us go through the sessions
as one by one
one second
yeah so the first first session of the
program
will be on 6th july and it will start
with an overview of all the resources
that your
all the resources that we discussed and
also the access to the program
so for the first session uh this will
include program orientation
group discussion uh to learn from the
participants of the program and about
the
about the research interest and
objectives so the orientation is also
is to get you familiarized with uh the
introduction to bioinformatics
so followed by this uh the first session
which is a
scheduled session to which focuses on
the problem
of cancer so in this session we will
also discuss about the complexity of
cancer biology and
the typical challenges that you see in
diagnostics at the
organ tissue or cellular level uh and we
will also discuss about molecular
factors that
that are involved in uh in tumor
development
that are there in uh in for basic and
both
basic and both translational research in
oncology
so in this study uh where we have also
a few examples like ilia said
to all of you that we have already
prepared a few examples so in
in one of the examples is a study where
you can see on the screen
a patient-derived cell line and this
in this xeno the xenograft models are
also used in another study
and we have also uh info i mean
data sets where we use clinical trials
information that offers a collection of
data to understand
and get information about the
diagnostics and also
treatment of cancer in patients
so uh the next session after that which
would be the second session
in the second session we will talk about
the technology after getting an overview
of
cancer and how deadly it is and what are
the different
characteristics to understand a cancer
cell so in the second session it will be
more about the technology as i'm saying
uh so it would be about
understanding how next generation
sequencing works
you will learn about shotgun sequencing
reads and then you'll
learn about how to make the data
structured
and then you will learn about uh
different uh bioinformatics methods
that uses uh like processing uh
where we will be doing uh both germline
and somatic mutations
we'll look at the analysis where we will
do mapping
detection uh variants you can see on the
screen and also
in this in this uh in the last part
so in the last part of the session we
will discuss about the interpretation so
how can you interpret this data and
along with this like
you will have access to the resources
that explains
all of this so that you kind of get
familiarized with what is being covered
and have a chance to do it at your at uh
at your own pace
so anytime that you feel that you have
uh
you have time to go through the
resources these are online courses that
are available on the
learn omix logic portal so in here i
mean we have different resources that it
starts from a very intro very basic
introduction and then
goes into different processing pipelines
and how data can be interpreted and how
you can
uh structure that data that could make
sense because it's from
a large large number of uh you know it's
a big data
and then you're transforming into a very
meaningful data set
so in this in this study in this uh
session
i mean uh we will learn about how
genomics is used
in biomedical drug discovery and how
genomics is used
in different other areas
in translational research so in the
third session
which will be on processing of
another type of sequencing data which is
the transcriptomics
data so in this uh session after
learning about the genomic processing
data and its application in biomedical
research
and precision medicine you will learn
how we can measure
uh functional proteins and
look at the mrna abundance and
understand accurately understand the
alternative splicing so
you saw examples of rna sequencing
before so going through this entire
process of rna sequencing doing the read
quality and pre-processing yourself
going and then mapping it to the
reference genome
and then understanding its role by
quantifying the genes and also the
transcripts
and in the same way after doing that you
would want to do the visual
visualization so um i think
this entire process is also to let the
scientific community know of what you
have under
what you have obtained from as a result
so expressing that in a visual form
and getting the visualization is a
scientific is a very important part of
our scientific
uh scientific things that we do uh every
day
so in that sense we will learn about how
you can correctly and
visualize uh the gene expression
information and also do pca to do that
and also go
go through annotation and interpretation
so
in this uh in the session uh we will be
going through the
the for example the processing pipelines
will prepare a full
pipeline and then go through different
type of analysis that we
do for gene expression uh data
so the session after that uh which will
be the fourth session
uh is on machine learning so you have
already learned about two
overview of two uh different
different technologies such as genomics
and transcriptomics and then
you would want to learn about how do you
you know do this
makes make sense of this data and do
this uh
to find out uh different patterns that
are lying within
a large number of other data sets also
so finding predictive modeling
or like understanding how this data what
this data
uh have uh information so this uh
complex collection where this is uh
about the data and the complex
collection
we are looking at different types of
characteristics we are looking between
correlation between a clinical
manifestation of disease
molecular patterns and how we can define
it
uh using different statistical analysis
right so machine learning approach
allows computational uh
power that could be applied to these
challenges so in this session uh we will
use machine learning
and during this uh during this time as i
was saying that there will be resources
allocated that will help you go through
and do this uh
on your own so you will also have access
to the coding platform
uh uploading uh playground which is
there and learn
where you can write and you know do
scripting in python and r and these also
ex
they are also like tutorials that takes
you through this entire process
so you know you know how to um apply r
and python
in your genomic or transcriptomics data
analysis
so uh yeah that would be an experience
and that uh these those
will be uh available uh to you
as uh the session goes on and we will
cover many of those aspects in these
live sessions
so after going through and learning
about how do you visualize and how can
you
actually analyze uh from different
project examples that we have prepared
for you
uh the next thing is to go and do it
yourself like finding those
uh important uh repositories on and
finding
the um data sets from those important
repositories like uh
sra jio and cbi and that that are there
in
ncbi and you already already discussed
about
the tcga repository so this session will
be about those
different repositories that are there
and very important for
any bioinformatician to you know explore
and
understand how to extract uh the
information that
you need for your project so we will be
discussing in that respect
and about the i mean opportunity many of
us here do not even understand the
opportunity that is
related to training like this i mean why
we are doing this
why why we are saying that our
independent
research is now very much possible and
within
reach of everyone why why so it's it's
because
uh the availability of data and yes i
mean
that that kind of data is available so
uh and ncbi is such a good example of
that you can see that how many
data sets have been uh already deposited
and underway it is growing rapidly every
day
so after learning about the data sets
and how to figure out and find data
we will again after the first phase i
think it would be
it would be five sessions and then after
the fifth session the sixth session
would be about next generation
sequencing where we will learn about uh
viral genomes
in the host transcriptome so uh here we
will also learn about oncolytic viruses
so that is one of the um one of the
feature of uh learning through precision
medicine program
is to learn about uh different aspects
of uh
transmissions uh from cancer and then
these uh different
uh viruses so here we will also learn
about like how
they are involved in tumor development
how do you connect from biology to
cancer and then um learn about
inflammation and tissue damage
here we will also learn about how can we
align annotate and
and do uh you know
mapping so we will learn about viral
genomes uh
and we will also learn about uh
alignment to databases of those uh you
know viral genomes
so after learning about that so the
second phase
in the where we are we are going to
learn about uh
different aspects of how can we
interpret uh
biological uh data from for virology and
infectious diseases so in the in this uh
session on
uh which is uh session seventh we will
learn about multiple sequence alignment
and phylogeny
so here we will learn about how can you
study uh
viral genomes for liver blood and
neural tissues and we will also learn to
prepare data and setting
setting up bioinformatics pipelines
where you will find
uh to do phylogenetic analysis
and multiple sequence alignment of these
genomes so i think um most of you are
familiar with
phylogenetic tree so phylogenetics
is a study phylogenetics in in the study
of phylogenetics you learn about the
lineages
between different different species and
how you can interpret
that so after
that so which is the seventh session so
this is spanned across
two sessions a week so i i think it
would be all right and we'll be going
through this
uh and you'll get enough time to
complete uh the assignments and also go
through some of the
some of the courses and materials and
data sets that we have prepared for you
so learning about that
then practicing so it's a very important
aspect of this program
is to do the hands-on hands-on tutorials
and do the hands-on
practice yourself to gain the most of it
and become an expert right so to do that
uh you have to be more comfortable by in
the on the
on the platform that you will have
access to during the
during the uh during the one month
program so
uh here we will learn about workflows
and pipelines in bioinformatics so we
have discussed already have seen
a lot of uh pipelines and workflows
there like uh
algorithms uh that are um that
are in that are put together in a
logical manner right
so and that uh in that way
we have a technology that helps us to
find out and you know detect those
challenges and
find out uh critical important important
information
to design a prop to design our research
correctly
so this is a very important role that
plays in bioinformatics and here we will
learn about you know detecting
and mapping those two databases and we
will also learn about
how you can understand about uh how
genomic uh
how genomics and genomes are and the
evolutionary time
correlates so this is something that we
have
uh planned for this session and here we
will also like uh
go through uh some of the
processes in this uh this is another one
of the example
this is a birth death uh
example of evolutionary study uh
so here you will also there are like
parameters that we will cover
that are there to understand this sort
of algorithm and what are different
algorithms to do this
and how they can be applied for a
problem
so about the problem um so now the next
session
is about the problem from infection
to pandemic from a viral adaptation
so here we will have an example about
the corona virus pandemic and we will do
uh take out such sequences from ncbi
virus
and we will do comparative studies where
we will compare
these four sequences genomic sequences
full sequences and find out like how
they can correlate and how
they make sense in you know activation
of immune response
uh and then cytokine storm which is
caused by valid replication
and also also could relate to what is
happening
currently um everywhere
so as i said uh that uh you would be
able to do it uh alongside with us
so we will use uh the tbi info platform
and where we have sections uh on on to
do this
uh which is virus quasi species so we'll
discuss this and we'll tell you like how
this is done um in session nine
so in after session nine the last
session
where this entire uh story uh comes to
an
conclusion where we are going to learn
about host pathogen interaction
so after applying and learning about all
of these
technologies and how they can be done
for different diseases sorry
here we are going to learn about what
are the strategies that we can apply to
you know overcome so we will talk about
vaccine design so how bioinformatics are
how you can consider data and then think
about vaccine design so you have a lot
of information coming from big data you
know about the sequences
you know about the gene expression now
you have figured out that this is a
protein of my interest and
i think these are the possible sites and
based on the mutations that i've seen in
the genomics
these are some of the places that we
should target
and that these are some of the epitope
binding sites so
based on all that information uh the
important uh thing
is to go for uh a
data driven hypothesis and that data
driven hypothesis
uh is something that we are going to uh
going to
discuss throughout the program so uh in
the session um we will cover
about uh some of the structure such
structures
uh how do you connect from uh
host response to viral replica
replication and then
implications of that to a cell organ and
tissue
so exploring different viral strategies
for exploitation of forced mechanism
machinery and uh the viral protein
production
so these are some of the topics uh and
sessions that
that are there for precision medicine
and i think one of the best part of this
is that
we also will be doing uh giving
and going through the courses the
coursework which actually
uh is is pretty amazing and that's what
we have heard from all of our
all of our uh participants so far so
after doing this and if you have any
confusion
and if you think that bioinformatics is
difficult because we are integrating so
many things we are integrating data
we are integrating algorithms we are
integrating complex machine learning
methods
it it sometimes gets like really thought
it thought it to be like sometimes it
gets really challenging
but we are here to help you out with
that because we have gone through this
entire process
over and over uh again and uh thought of
different strategies that actually uh
so with that uh i would now
uh maybe pass it back to sunalika
and uh will be happy to take any
question and answer
and if you have any questions and maybe
i can also look into the
zoom yes doctor
we have a question do i need to have a
specific
background to take the course
uh yeah i think there is the programs
the way that we have planned them
starts from the basics so as as i told
you that if you have a basic background
in biology and
if you have interest if you have keen
interest in doing this
and if you have uh something to do
something to do with research so i think
this is a program for you
because uh what we will be going through
is a research
based training and uh this will take you
to what is happening not just like
you know what what we have put together
but uh taking real examples like
the articles that have published now so
it's
actually correlates a lot with uh what
is happening in the industry but
also what is happening in in acad
current research in academia as well so
that's the opportunity that you have
and uh if you would want to know and
learn from the very basic
we also have the coursework to help you
with that and
along with that we have mentorship and
then we have also a research fellowship
program
so it's just not that you can you can do
everything in
all of this in one month i think that's
that's quite
uh quite a challenging thing to do but
it's a very good
thing to start with somewhere start from
somewhere and this is the
that sort of opportunity that takes you
to all of the
great topics that are there for
discussion in scientific community today
and then uh choose and understand and
decide
that what is that that you would want to
contribute to
so these are some of the some of the
thoughts that i'll leave uh leave you
with
so now uh sanadika if anyone has any
other question i would be happy to
answer that
that as well thank you so much dr mohit
we have a question for the
uh dr japoliano dr bashar asks is there
any mechanism to prevent the
differentiation of
mes to adrn
yeah actually he answered me on uh the
private
uh message thank you for that okay okay
thanks so much
okay so if there are any more questions
you can post it
on this chat box
i'm just sharing my screen let me just
quickly take you through the
preregistration and the registration for
the program
so by the email you would have got this
pre-registration link and if you don't
have one i would be sharing with you on
the chat box itself you can pre-register
yourself for the program here
now when i say pre-register it's just a
formality to be a part of the program so
that we get your
details and on this pre-registration
page you would be
able to find all the details which are
associated with the program
what all would be covered the session
details are mentioned
as well and also we have answered few of
the frequently asked questions
so you can just go through the uh
pre-registration page
and find your answers also all these
session details will
dr mohit explained are mentioned on the
pre-registration page
now as i told pre-registration is just
to fill out the form so that we get your
entry but to proceed ahead with your
registration and your enrollment in the
program
you need to proceed with the
registration program
page here is the link
once you proceed with this program page
you would have to click on start your
application
and you would get three levels beginner
intermediate and advanced
the the three levels they are basically
uh based on the basis of
the provisions that you would be getting
for the program
and the provisions are mentioned here
very clearly you can go through each of
them
and pick the um level which suits your
requirements the best
and we also have opportunities for
people who are
who are looking for scholarships for
their research work
and those who are interested to get
scholarships they can mail me at
marketing at the rate pine dot bio
and i would be uh glad to help you out
with the scholarship process for your
research work
and you can also mail dr mohit at
mohit at the ratepine.bio and we would
be happy to clear all your queries
uh we have a question the tertiary
monday last how frequently these
programs are offered
so uh deeptha shri if i'm pronouncing a
name right we
i have these programs ongoing every
month but yes different topics
so uh we had bioinformatics for
infectious diseases then we had a
machine learning
that's the ongoing one we have chem
informatics program as well
which is ongoing but yes uh we won't be
repeating them
so we for the the precision that the
precision medicine one it would be
starting on
july 6 and it would end on
5th of august and i hope that answers
your question
and corp calmly asks i just begin with
bioinformatics i noticed that many by
informations use mac os
okay so first of all that's not an issue
at all
uh i am actually using windows right now
so what are the advantages of mac os
compared to linux or
window doctor mohit would you like to
answer this in detail please
i mean i don't think that there's any
advantages per state to mac os
i just think that because it's based on
unix
you can run some linux right there from
the terminal
and a lot of people end up using it so i
think that's the main reason
i don't think that you should be
thinking that you know if you want to go
into bioinformatics you have to use a
mac os computer
it's just something of preference
yes exactly i believe the same so it
doesn't matter whatever system you have
and whatever specification you have
while talking about specification it
just reminded me that many of the
researchers
uh they are the the basic shortcoming in
their
research work is their specification
there are many people who are not able
to actually update their
systems and get the required
specification to complete their research
work
and that's where our server chiba info
server comes
into play and helps out carry out
different sorts of
big data analysis all at once uh
and not giving uh any you know
a thing to your systems uh specification
yes okay so uh
i have explained all the registration
and the preregistration
forms and also the sessions i hope are
well clear to you if
anyhow you want to go through this the
syllabus once again in a detailed manner
we also have the syllabus mentioned on
the
syllabus page i am sharing the link with
you as well
and let us know if you have any doubts
thank you so much for joining us with
the session today
it was really great to have you all with
us thank you everyone bye bye
hope to see you soon in the sessions
thank you so much
thank you thank you so much dr
thank you thank you so much have a great
day